Okay, so in this lecture we're going to
talk about neural differential
equations.
So this is a super popular field of
scientific machine learning.
And again, the idea is to kind of put
neural networks into our traditional
scientific workflows.
And you're going to see that uh
these are very related to these hybrid
scientific machine learning workflows
that we've been talking about in the in
the previous few lectures.
Um so
I'm going to skip over this cuz we just
we just covered this whole example.
Um
Yeah, so we just have this one lecture
on neural differential equations and
then I'm going to move on to a an
introduction to JAX, which will be the
the next lecture.
Uh and then we have symbolic regression
model discovery, course summary, and
then and then the final two lectures,
which are guest lectures on machine
learning for biology and chemistry.
So this is what this lecture's going to
look like. We're going to Well, first of
all, I'm going to tell you what a neural
differential equation is. Uh
hands up, who's heard of this term
before or even has used neural
differential equations? Anyone?
One. Yeah.
Okay, brilliant. So it's a new topic.
That's that's good.
What I'm going to do is tell you the
link between neural differential
equations and neural network
architectures. This is really
interesting and provides a bridge
between kind of our world of
PDEs and and the world of neural
networks. Um
And then I'm going to tell you about
state-of-the-art neural differential
equations. And I have two examples of
models. One is a coupled oscillatory RNN
and another are diffusion models, which
you can think of as neural differential
equations. So
I'll explain all of this as I get to it.
So by the end of the lecture, you'll be
able to define what a neural
differential equation is. You'll be able
to understand this connection between uh
PDE solvers and neural network
architectures and
be more aware of some of the
state-of-the-art applications of these
types of models.
Um
So
what I'm going to talk about is this
Lotka-Volterra
system. So who has seen this this
uh dynamical model before?
Okay, yeah. It's
it's often used or often studied as
well. It's very famous, actually.
Uh so this is
an ordinary differential equation.
It's a dynamical system
and it's heavily used in in
biology to to model kind of
predator-prey
dynamics.
And so what we're modeling is two
variables, the
X and X and Y here in the equations.
Uh which just model the population of of
a predator population and the prey prey
distribution.
A prey a prey population.
And if you solve this differential
equation or ordinary differential
equation,
which is coupled, so we have a equation
for the the population of the prey and
the population of the of the predator.
Uh the types of solutions you get are
are these uh solutions where the you
know, the the prey starts to eat uh the
predator starts to eat the prey and so
the the uh
uh the prey populations go down and then
the predator
populations go down after that because
there's less prey. So you have kind of a
light system. And you also have an
oscillatory system. So you see the
dynamics oscillate through time.
And of course, the kind of
the characteristics of these
oscillations, like the frequency and uh
the height and etc. etc. all just depend
on these kind of constants that we
choose in our underlying differential
equation.
And then things like the maximum prey
birth rate, the effect of the predators
on the prey, etc. etc.
Who's with me? Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Okay, so
first question, how do we solve or how
would you solve this ordinary
differential equation? If I if I gave
you this ODE
and maybe I gave you the starting
populations of the prey and the
predator,
what would be a like traditional way of
solving solving this this ODE?
Uh yeah, go on.
Yeah.
Numerical methods, yeah. So can you be
more precise? What what
Yeah. A Runge-Kutta would be a really
good like higher order maybe would be a
good option.
Um
So for the purpose of explaining what
ODEs are, I'm going to tell you how you
would solve it with an Euler method,
which is the simplest possible
way of solving it. This this is a stiff
problem, so it probably would give
not very accurate solution, but it's for
the purpose of demonstration, I think
that's what we're going to use.
So
to solve this with the Euler method,
we would simply discretize the the
the derivatives here on the left-hand
side with our numerical approximations,
very simple.
Um and then if you just rearrange this,
you just end up with a super simple kind
of time stepping algorithm for for the
population dynamics and the prey
dynamics for the population dynamics
through time.
Okay, so
now let's get to the interesting bit. So
when we when we create this model,
you know, this is all models are
approximate.
And we made a lot of assumptions when we
when we designed this
ordinary differential equation. So
I've just listed a few. There are
actually many many of assumptions from
the of the system. So
some of them are that the prey
population always finds ample food.
The food supply of the predator
population depends entirely on the on
the size of the prey population.
The rate of change of the population is
proportional to its size. Predators have
limitless limitless appetites.
Who here sees that there is like
actually a lot of kind of assumptions
that are baked into these kind of rate
of change equations?
Yeah.
Oh, you just you just hand up, yeah.
Yeah, that was all I needed.
So
what you can see is there's a lot of
assumptions, right?
And this might not reflect like a a real
biological system. In fact, it probably
doesn't because there are so many
complicated factors that affect
populations and external factors, etc.
Um
So what we're going to try and do is
learn the right-hand side of this
equation
instead of just saying that we know what
these coefficients are. We're actually
going to try and learn learn what this
differential equation is.
So that this is the setup that we're
going to assume. So just imagine that we
have some observations of of the of the
predator and the prey's populations
through time.
So imagine we have these black dots here
that we've we've gone out into the field
and recorded these these populations.
So can anyone kind of give me an idea
about how you would try and
make this more flexible or maybe try and
learn kind of the the right-hand side of
these equations?
Yeah.
Kind of do it in a similar way to like
the last lecture, where you
Yeah.
parameters now that you can learn Yeah.
start off with with some of them
uh Yeah.
Yeah.
Very nice. Yeah. So what parameters
would you try and learn?
Maybe like just the coefficients. Yeah.
I mean, that doesn't really solve the
problem with like all the assumptions we
have. Yeah. Um
so maybe like direction counts or
something. Yeah, okay. Good. So So what
you're suggesting is like treating
alpha, beta,
delta, gamma as as like learnable
values.
And then what you also said is to have
like a numerical solver that solves that
system given those learnable values and
then differentiates through it to learn
the the values, yeah. Yeah, very good.
So
can anyone think of any other ways? So
that's that's a really good way.
Anyone have any other thoughts?
Okay.
So
um
what neural differential equations do or
or what we're going to do in this
problem is we're going to say
yeah, we're going to treat some of these
coefficients as learnable, but actually
we're going to take a step further than
that. We're going to say
not only that some of the coefficients
learnable, but actually some of the
functions itself are learnable.
So in in the previous example, we had
this beta equals X times Y. This is an
assumption about the the
prey dynamics.
Uh where it depends this is the factor
that
modulates the prey dynamics based on the
the predator's population.
So we might not That's quite a strong
assumption to say it's like a
multiplication.
Uh so we might say actually it might be
a more complicated function than just a
multiplication function that is the kind
of
that does the crossover between the two
populations.
And so we don't know what that is. Maybe
we're just going to approximate that
with some learnable function, which
we're just going to learn with a neural
network. So the network itself is going
to take in the the prey dynamics and the
population dynamics and then produce
some some
some rate of change contribution to this
ODE.
Can do the same for the for the prey for
the predator's dynamics as well.
Or and maybe for the other term here, we
might be sure that it just depends on Y,
but maybe we just don't know what the
coefficient is. So So we can kind of mix
and match how flexible you want these
these right-hand side terms of the
equation to be.
So what we actually
call this when we have a
differential equation
and also partial differential equation
can can also be.
Um when we have a differential equation
which has a neural network inside of it,
we just call this whole thing a neural
differential equation. That's what we
define as an NDE.
Make sense to everyone?
Okay.
So I think we'll take a break and then
we'll talk about how we're going to
train this
afterwards. So let's take 10 10-15
minutes.
Let's get back into this.
So a neural differential equation is
very simple or defined very simply. It's
just to say
it's a differential equation. Can be an
ODE, can be a partial differential
equation more generally.
Uh
where some of the terms of the
differential equation are are neural
networks.
So someone asked in the break, what's
the difference between neural
differential equations and PINNs?
Can anyone tell me the difference? How
is a PINN different?
Yeah. You are approximating two uh
variables, so to say X and Y.
Yeah. Which is one. Yeah.
Yeah.
And
and then
Yeah. E 6 times over S. Yeah. Neural.
Yeah.
Neural on the solvers. Yeah. In space.
Yeah. Yeah, you got it.
You got it. Yeah. So a PD a PINN,
physics-informed neural network.
Remember we write for a physics-informed
network, we say the solution to the
differential equation is approximated by
a neural network.
So in this case we would for a a PINN
would say X and Y here is is
approximated by a some neural network as
a function of of time.
And the PINN offers a way to solve the
differential equation.
Here the the neural network is not
solving the differential equation, it's
just part of the differential equation
itself. So it's a bit different.
So
uh yeah, how do we solve
this system of ODEs numerically?
So now that we've replaced the terms
with a with a neural network, who would
How how could we solve this?
A Any Anyone else?
Who hasn't answered yet?
Can anyone guess?
Yeah, please. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. So we we can use uh the
same method to solve this. Even though
this is a neural network, this is just a
mathematical function at the end of the
day which is analytical.
Um
so we do the same thing. We just uh
discretize the the derivatives just like
we did before.
And
now we just call the neural network
every time we do the time step uh just
like we would call the X times Y
function when we when we do the standard
Euler solver.
So
we just end up with a very similar time
stepping algorithm where now inside this
time stepping algorithm we just have
some neural networks that are that are
called every every time step.
So what I can do is just
again, write this as some pseudo code.
So we just have some some function which
takes our
initial values of the of the populations
here and the time step and
now we also input the the parameters of
the neural network.
And then we just carry our we just do
our Euler Euler algorithm. So we just do
our very simple time stepping, just
rewriting these equations into the code.
And inside this for algorithm we again
we have a a neural network that we're
calling.
So who thinks this looks similar to
these kind of to the solver in the loop
hybrid method and also that inverse that
method that I just talked about?
Looks similar?
If you just think a bit from a code
perspective, like again we have is a
function, we have a for loop, and inside
the for loop a neural network is being
called.
This is like algorithmically very sim
even though it's a completely different
task, algorithmically it's exactly the
same as this these hybrid methods that
we've been talking about.
Um so this is an example this is an
example of a
this is an example of a hybrid
simulation workflow. It's just another
way to think of it.
Okay, so now the final question we have
to ask is how are we going to train
these neural networks? So suppose I give
you these these population measurements
from some unknown dynamics.
Uh these points here, how are we going
to train the neural network based on
this on this data to learn these these
neural network terms?
Can anyone tell me a loss a loss
function?
Yeah. Constants.
Yeah.
Bias function.
Good. Yeah. I think you're starting to
get it now. So yeah, it's again, we just
think about what what the inputs and
what the outputs of this of this
function.
So we just start with our initial
initial values which we which we're told
from our data.
And the outputs are the final the final
populations. We can also output the the
the whole population as a function of
time from the solver.
And so we can just say the loss function
is you know, the outputs of the Euler
solver, this function that we're calling
uh and the difference between that and
the observed data that we have.
So whatever we have a data observed data
point, we just spit out that data point
um from the from the solver and we just
create a loss function to match it. It's
very simple.
Again, auto diff super powerful
technique, it's now allowing us to solve
or train neural differential equations
as well as PINNs as well as hybrid
workflows as well as neural operators,
you know.
So uh yeah, this paper called Universal
Differential Equations, they they did
they studied using neural differential
equations to solve this uh
Lotka-Volterra system. And they did
exactly this. So they had they assumed
that their PDE had this structure with
some learnable components in these in
these neural networks.
And uh this is a plot from the paper and
and so what they're showing here is the
data that they trained the the NDE on.
Um and uh the
once once the network had been trained,
this is they're also plotting the the
solution
you know, the the population dynamics as
a function of time output by the solver.
And basically they were able to exact
exactly match this data. This is
actually a fairly simple kind of
learning task.
Uh
so once we've got once we've trained the
neural networks, kind of the next
question is
can we
can we learn anything about the physics?
So these are kind of still kind of black
box functions. They've learned some
function that we're not sure about.
So how how could you kind of learn
something about the physics once you
train these networks? Can anyone think
of what you might do?
Okay, so I'll tell you cuz it's not not
immediately obvious.
But
what you can do is just plot the the
neural network as a function of its
inputs. The network here is just a
function of X and Y.
So I can this is just a 2D uh
you know, a scalar value as a function
of 2D. So it just looks like an image.
So I can just plot this as a function of
X and Y.
And depending on the data and the
underlying dynamics, uh
you can just sometimes just do symbolic
regression on this function.
Or just even look at it like it manual
inspection
and see that this is just X times Y. So
so what people people often do once
they've trained these neural
differential equations is is do a extra
step on top which is symbolic regression
of these trained networks to try and
discover the the underlying symbolic
form of the of the expression.
So I mean it's not always possible
depending on how complicated the
dynamics are, but in this case
they did assume that it was just a
simple underlying XY kind of curve to to
learn.
Yeah. Is it possible to learn
which
Uh
I
um
condition
Yeah, I it's it's in the data that we're
training. So
I'm just imagining if you if you didn't
have the initial condition, I guess you
could treat these these inputs as
learnable values.
I I think that's possible cuz this would
just be a part of theta and we would
just take it just two learnable values.
And then it would become some kind of
weird hybrid where we're kind of like
learning
the initial conditions but also the PDE
at the same time. But yeah, I think I
think it's possible. Yeah.
But yeah, we just as Ralph said, we just
the it's just in the data for now. Yeah.
Okay.
So what's really cool is that I can take
this learned
PDE and just carry out this hybrid
solver for longer time steps. Like I
don't just have to simulate
uh
for the the length of the data. Like
once I train this different neural
differential equation, I can just carry
on simulating, just calling the the
solver longer and longer.
And what's really nice is that we see
that this model kind of generalizes
well. So it's actually learned that the
process is oscillatory and and gives us
a stable prediction of the of the
dynamics for very long time values.
Yeah.
It's it's also connecting to the
previous example. Yeah.
Yeah. What if you have in your
loops
some if statements, some adaptive step
size or termination criteria? Yeah. Can
you explain to this auto
differentiation? Yeah, so it So it
depends on the package. So some packages
can do kind of dynamic auto
differentiation.
Uh so for example, PyTorch can
dynamically like differentiate through
dynamic graphs.
Um
so
and and the way that it does it is just
every iteration you just redraw the
computational graph. So each iteration
the graph is actually fixed and then you
can get a gradient.
But the issue is that uh you know,
that's a highly dynamic code, so it
might be quite hard to learn. Like the
actual kind of learning learning task is
might be difficult.
But
But But people have done things like
kind of learn adaptive meshing, for
example. Like that is possible. Uh you
just have to be able to frame frame the
kind of algorithm in the right way.
But yeah, so
it's a good idea, I think.
Uh okay, so
so this when we roll this out, um it
generalizes really well. So
let's just think about comparing this to
a a naive way of trying to
um predict this data set. So
what what I'm doing here is
let's just imagine that we're having it
we're going to predict the data set by
just saying that a neural network which
takes in the time coordinate and tries
to predict what the population is.
So, we're just going to forget that we
even know about this PDE and just say we
have some data and we're going to match
our observed data to the prediction of
the of the network at each time step.
And we'll train it with a super very
similar loss function using our observed
data here.
And what I've plotted here is the
What
the paper didn't actually train this
network, but I've plotted what I can
guarantee you would be the the result of
this if you train such a network.
And this would be the result where you
the network
uh
is able to match where it has where it
has streaming data and give you a good
prediction.
But as soon as I query this this naive
network for a time value that it hasn't
seen in its training data, it's just
going to give you a really bad
prediction.
This is just a generalization error of
of neural network showing up here.
So, my question is this like why why is
this left-hand side approach? Why is the
neural differential equation so much
better than just training like a naive
network in this situation in this
situation?
Who knows the answer?
Yeah, go on.
Are you not sure? Yeah.
Well, well, it's it's going to be
because we're learning the problem,
right? Yeah. And and not the solution.
So, like
It makes sense that we generalize if if
we
Yeah.
You're you're halfway there. Yeah,
you're
Yeah. Somehow it has to learn the
underlying distributions and when it
sees values distributions that it Yeah.
recognizes that with um
regular MLP
Yeah.
learn the underlying distributions.
Yeah, go on. Somehow here
it picks the size
Yeah. All right, you can define the size
of the step.
Yes. Probably failed.
Yeah. Some start going to reach
Yeah.
That's that's the key insight here is is
think about the inputs to these two
different neural networks.
This neural network here or both these
networks take in X and Y as their
inputs. They don't take in the time
value as an input. There's no
time dependence of these of these
functions they're learning.
Whereas this function only takes the
time value.
And when we query this for later times,
this doesn't have examples
uh at later times.
But what you can observe is the dynamics
here are bounded. So, there's this
so-called phase space of the system,
right? Where you can plot X and Y as a
function uh together.
And the X and Y values only range
between say 0 and and 10 here.
So, during training what
as long as we make sure that the NDE is
trained on one full cycle, the whole
range of the XY values, you can be
pretty sure that this network's going to
be in in distribution whenever it's
queried at later times.
Another way of saying this is very
simply that the NDE has a lot of
structure to it.
Like with as well as these networks,
we're assuming a really rigid structure
of the underlying dynamics. Like with
the
assuming it's a first-order system rate
of change equation.
This also just adds a lot of kind of
physics constraints into the into the
prediction that it produces.
So, yeah, this this model generalizes
well because it the network sees the
entire phase space during its training.
So, a nice way of plotting these kind of
systems is to plot X as a function of Y
and you can just see
as the system evolves in time, it just
goes around this kind of circle.
You've probably all seen these kind of
phase diagrams before.
Yeah. Okay.
Does that make sense to everyone?
How it generalizes?
So, I mean
maybe it depends on your definition of
generalizing. This network is just
seeing inputs that it's already seen
during training, but it's kind of
generalizing in time when you solve the
differential equation.
Cool. So, uh
summary of neural differential
equations. So, this is the key idea. Use
the neural network to represent parts of
the the differential equations we don't
know. This is the definition of a neural
differential equation.
And then as I've shown you in that
example, we can solve NDEs using
numerical methods.
Just like we do with traditional uh
differential equations.
We can train NDEs with auto diff just
matching the outputs of the simulator
with respect to
but just matching the outputs of the
simulator with some training data.
They can be used to discover the
underlying dynamics. That's exactly what
the neural network's trying to do.
And they can also just be thought of as
a hybrid technique that you know, we're
just using auto grad to differentiate
through a a solver basically.
Okay. So, I've covered the kind of
uh
first part of the lecture which is what
is a neural differential equation.
So, now we're going to go into this
super fascinating link between kind of
neural differential equations and and
neural networks themselves. And
this is a really kind of interesting
bridge between the field of machine
learning and PDEs and it's really
interesting to learn. So,
we'll cover this and then and then I
think uh next lecture we'll probably get
on to the state-of-the-art applications
of these of these models.
So, we can define more generally uh
a neural ordinary differential equation.
Um and so we can just take that kind of
uh look look to look to Volterra system
and just
abstract it to just a just any ordinary
differential equation which we can write
like this.
Where we just have some vector that
depends on a single variable T.
Uh and its rate of change just depends
is a some vector-valued function
uh here.
And so we can just say this whole
right-hand side of our ODE is just a
learnable function. So,
it's probably a neural network, but it
could also be
a combination of kind of mathematical
expressions with a neural network or
whatever you whatever you want.
Okay.
So, we can solve this using a whole
library of different ODE solvers. Um
again, I'm just showing you the Euler
method, but of course there are much
better options depending on the actual
difficulty of the of the problem.
But if we solve this with a with an
Euler method again, we just
approximate the left-hand side with its
numerical derivative and rearrange it a
little bit and we just get an an
expression for the solution
at each time step.
And to evaluate the the solution at each
time step, we just we inside of that
evaluation is some
evaluation of the neural network.
Everyone with me so far?
Okay.
So, what's what's super useful is to
actually just draw this out as a
diagram.
Um and then you can start seeing
connections. So,
if I just
write this workflow out as a as a
graphical diagram here. So, so at the
bottom here is the the current time
step, the value of X.
And then we're just going to evaluate
the neural network and we're just going
to add that to X and and also times it
by the the time step here.
So, as a as a as a kind of graph
diagram,
what does this remind you of?
Anyone Anyone
think that this looks familiar somehow?
Yeah, go on.
Residual connection.
Yeah, absolutely.
This is exactly the diagram for a
residual connection in a in a neural
network.
Remember a residual connection just
takes X X here in a neural network
would be like the hidden state of the
network or just some input.
And we pass it through some neural
network layer. It could be like a
convolutional layer or fully connected
layer or whatever.
And then we just add a skip connection.
So, we just add that the hidden state
back to the to the output of the neural
network.
So, what you should immediately start
realizing is that
this discretized version of the ordinary
differential equation
is doing a residual step or at least
each step is doing a
each
time step here is is a residual residual
network.
So, yeah, this is the kind of key
insight here.
So, what I can do is I can just draw out
This is now just a drawing of a ResNet.
You know, what we do with ResNets is we
stack these residual layers together and
have like 10-layer ResNets, 50-layer
ResNets.
And what you can see in the
the ResNets are actually just Euler ODE
solvers. Like
each ResNet layer here is just doing it
one step of a of an Euler solver.
And kind of in the limit of an infinite
number of layers, so as like our time
step goes to zero,
mathematically ResNets just solve this
ordinary differential equation here.
So, yeah, training a ResNet is
also just the same when we're learning
these weights of the ResNet here, it's
also just the same as learning the
right-hand side of the of the ODE.
I'll just let that sink in cuz that's
like quite a
important connection to try and relate
the two fields.
So, this was uh
this kind of link was just kind of
talked about and interpreted in this
paper. This is a really
really famous paper. It's definitely
worth reading Neural Ordinary
Differential Equations.
Um and yeah, it's it's simply this.
ResNets are Euler ODE solvers in the
limit.
Okay. So,
we define the neural ordinary
differential equation as this.
Um
and we have this learnable function
here. But as we've been talking about
when
we just assume that we use an Euler
solver. And when we use that Euler
solver, we saw that it it gives us a
residual connection or looks like a res
net.
Who else could we use? If if we know
that this is like a stiff problem to
solve as we were talking about before.
There are many other numerical solvers,
right?
Yeah.
Well, as I can point to the explicit
Euler for stiff problems, you might
consider implicit. Implicit methods,
yeah. Any other Any other options? There
there are many, obviously.
Yeah, so you mentioned Runge-Kutta.
So
we could we could use that, for example.
Um so I'm not going to go into how this
is method is derived, but you can there
are many class classes you can you can
take on this.
Uh but this is the this is the time
stepping algorithm that you would use
and it um it's just a more complex
computation at the end of the day.
Uh where we computing these intermediate
vectors, these K1, K2, K3, K4.
Uh which just have these expressions
here. And
all of these are just calling the neural
network in in kind of a more complex
mathematical function.
But it's the same deal. We just we start
with a time step, we get an output time
step, and it just depends on the neural
network. And so what I can draw here is
that kind of computational graph of all
those kind of calls of the neural
network and how they're added together
and connected together.
So
now that we already know that that we
can interpret these neural differential
equation solvers as neural network
architectures, right? The Euler solver
was a res net.
We can just interpret this as like a
custom neural network architecture.
This is like a custom residual block
that's just more complicated than just a
simple skip connection. It's got a bunch
of other stuff going on.
But you could think of creating a neural
network which is just composed of all of
these residual blocks and then just
training that to do any machine learning
task like we would like we would do a
res net.
So this is the next insight is that kind
of other solvers define other neural
network architectures. So
uh you can have the same PDE, but the
way that you discretize it might change
the the architecture that falls out.
Um so I have a slide here that's very
dense. Uh I don't have the time to to go
through it, but
if you're interested, have a look at
at the slide later.
Um but what what I'm showing here is a
that if you just think of a
convolutional neural network, a CNN, in
in particular just a a 1D convolutional
layer with with just three weights in
the filter.
You can actually derive the kind of
underlying PDE that that network solves
in the limit of like a a
an infinite number of CNN layers.
So yeah, the question I'm asking here
is, okay, so what if we know that neural
network architectures
in the limit solve differential
equations, what differential equation
does a CNN solve?
And it turns out this this CNN solves
this this underlying PDE here.
So it's it's super interesting to kind
of
reinterpret neural network architectures
as solving differential equations. And
And this is kind of the
the key key link here is that we can
interpret neural network as as
discretized differential equation
solvers.
And once we've formed that bridge, we've
got some really interesting things we
can learn. So we can take, for example,
all of our understanding of PDEs and and
their solutions and how hard they are to
solve and all these interesting things
we know about PDEs.
And we can help feed that into
understanding understanding which
architectures to use to design neural
networks to have certain properties.
Also to help us understand how to train
those neural network architectures,
right?
The link also goes the other way. We can
take some of our best architectures that
we know from machine learning, things
like transformers or, you know, residual
networks and such and and help us maybe
solve PDEs or or think about framing
PDEs in a different way.
So
this is a super cool link. and indeed it
can help us kind of interpret the the
dynamics of of of neural network
architectures.
Okay.
So I hope everyone understands that
link. Have you got any questions on this
before? I I do have time to move on, I
think, to the next part. So
Everyone see the link?
Okay.
Good.
So yeah, um I'll talk about uh
I'll start talking about these coupled
oscillatory ODEs. So So what I want to
show you now are some kind of
applications of neural differential
equations that are that are interesting.
And uh
there's um
a kind of realization here that
in in that very first example that I
showed you where we were using a neural
differential equation to learn like a
physical system, that the the
Lotka-Volterra dynamics.
Uh yeah, in that case we we we actually
wanted to learn like the dynamics of the
system, but what I've just showed you is
that uh neural differential equation
solvers can be thought can be used as
just neural network architectures. And
And in that way
we can actually just use neural
differential equations to solve machine
learning tasks rather than just to learn
these underlying dynamics.
We can just think of this NDE solver as
just some
new custom neural network architecture
with some learnable parameters.
And it just takes some inputs and
produces some outputs and we're just
going to use that as a machine learning
model.
We can train these NDEs on like machine
learning type tasks. So we can take We
can say the input here instead of it
being something physically
understandable like the initial prey or
pop population dynamics.
Instead it's going to be some machine
learning input like a image that we want
to classify. And And the output of the
of the solver
might be like a a classification of the
class of that image. And And when we
train when we train the NDE, we're just
going to try and learn this kind of
non-linear non-linear mapping.
So yeah, this is the key The next key
idea is uh
discretized NDE solvers can be thought
of as custom architectures. Why not use
an NDE to model any any data set and not
just a physical system?
Yeah. So is the NDE kind of in a way
discovering the equation solving it?
Yeah.
I mean it is, for sure, because this is
we're assuming we're discretizing a
underlying differential equation. So
which is really interesting because you
can Not only can you just learn a a good
function that solves this task with high
accuracy, you can then look at that PDE
that is actually learned underneath and
use that to help interpret the the
neural network.
And that might tell you something
interesting about the the types of
functions that it's learning. So
this is why this link is so interesting
cuz these neural differential equations
help us interpret the kind of dynamics
of the neural network.
So you could look, for example, at how
that this hidden state of the network
evolves over time and and see how it
changes the input to the output, for
example.
Okay.
Uh so this paper that uh talked
introduced neural ordinary differential
equations did exactly this. They they
looked at them from a machine learning
perspective and they trained these
neural differential equations on machine
learning tasks.
So the first thing they tried was just
simple classification on MNIST. This is
like one of our most basic benchmarks in
machine learning.
And it does a does a good job of
of of modeling this modeling this data
set.
So they compared like a the res net,
which we can think of as just a Euler
solver,
to this ARK net. So this is discretizing
the the solver in a
uh in a higher order way.
And it For this problem, because it's
such a simple task, they both perform
kind of similarly. But in general, there
are kind of differences between the
solver that you the discretized solver
that you choose and the kind of
performance.
So we're going to talk about some more
advanced applications of using NDEs to
solve more more complex kind of machine
machine learning tasks.
So the next task we're going to think
about is this this task. This is a
really
important task in machine learning. A
lot of people work on this and this is
kind of
carrying out human activity recognition.
So this is like we have our smart smart
watches and those smart watches have
accelerometers in them and they record,
you know, the X, Y, and Z acceleration
as a function of time.
And so the task of kind of human
activity recognition is to given these
time series of the acceleration, can I
actually classify what the human what
the human is doing at that point in
time?
So in this case, the the human is is uh
walking up the stairs. And so you would
hope that there's enough kind of
information or characteristics in these
signals that we can kind of uniquely
determine what what that activity is.
But this is this is prime for a machine
learning algorithm. Like we don't really
know the the the the map between the
acceleration and the and the the actual
activity.
And and we want to learn that learn that
that function or that map.
So how do you think we normally What How
do you think like would be a baseline
approach to do this? What What would be
a reasonable machine learning
or neural network to to do this this
prediction?
Anyone know how how it's been done
before?
So that that this is the task. You're
given this time series of these three
components and you want to produce the
class of the of the activity.
What type of network could you use?
Anyone know of any neural networks that
deal with time series data very well?
Yeah. Like kind of
LSTM. LSTM, yeah.
Or more simply, just a
GRU, yeah. So
these are examples of of recurrent
neural networks.
So, RNNs.
Uh who's heard of RNNs before? Just
checking.
Yeah, most of you. Okay, good.
So, this is what an an RNN would do, a
recursive neural network.
Uh they have a
neural network architecture that looks
like this.
Uh
and what it is is just a neural network
uh that takes in
the the input at each time step. So, in
this case, it the network would take in
the acceleration XYZ value at each time
step.
You That would be one input to the
network. Another input would be what we
call the hidden state of the of the RNN.
This is just another vector
which you can think of as holding some
sort of memory or kind of yeah,
persistent kind of representation of the
problem.
Um
you pass those inputs and the network
produces a new hidden state based on
those or updates the hidden state based
on those inputs.
And then we just recursively
do that uh for every time step. So, then
we feed in the next acceleration value,
then we then we call the network again
and just unroll for as many time steps
as we have.
Um and typically, this neural network
here is is uh the same neural network.
So, it has it shares its weights across
each time step. So, we don't we don't
have separate neural networks in each
box.
Uh and then once you've absorbed all of
the or processed all of these inputs,
all of these time series values,
then you're
uh you might have an an extra network on
top uh that or a head a so-called head
of the RNN
which just produces some classes classes
the output. So, decodes the the hidden
state into a class.
And then you train this with like a
cross entropy like a standard standard
uh classification loss for the network.
Everyone understand this so far?
Okay.
So, this is how we would do it and these
RNNs or or variants of RNNs, for
example, like LSTMs or GRUs or or
whatever more advanced
uh recursive networks,
they perform well for sure. They can get
high accuracy on the task.
Uh but what we
struggle with or what what I would argue
we've been doing a lot in machine
learning research is just to try and
figure out what the right architecture
of of this
uh RNN cell is. Like, what what what
architecture should we use?
Should we use a MLP like a fully
connected network or a CNN or should we
use a LSTM cell like something more
advanced?
But I think that's not obvious when we
when we're training these kind types of
ML problems.
So,
what we're going to try and do is use
physics or neural differential equations
to try and help us design a neural
network architecture that has some kind
of physics principle in it. As a maybe a
more principled way of designing this
RNN.
So, what we're eventually going to end
up with is like a RNN cell which has
like a physics constraint in it that we
think is suitable for this data set.
And what the what the physics constraint
is that we're going to say is well, what
is this this data looks oscillatory. I
think that's fair to say.
The the the person is kind of walking up
the stairs. This is an oscillatory
problem if you look at the the
acceleration values. It's got kind of
a set frequency to the spikes as the
person walks up the stairs.
So, this is kind of a general concept
that we're just going to try and put
into this
uh
uh architecture that we're designing.
Okay.
So, we're going to use a neural
differential equation. That means that
we have to
use a differential equation to solve or
to represent this problem somehow.
So, we have to pick a an appropriate
differential equation to start to start
using.
Uh or to help us design this neural
network architecture.
So, the differential equation we're
going to look at is the one that
describes uh coupled harmonic
oscillators.
So, what is a coupled hot harmonic
oscillator? Well,
uh this just describes in the simplest
case like a a mass on a spring.
Uh
you know,
uh just the oscillatory uh displacement
of that mass.
But what makes it coupled is that we
don't just have one mass, we actually
have multiple masses connected together
with with multiple springs and and then
you get uh kind of coupled dynamics of
or coupled oscillations of the of the
masses.
So, who's seen this before in like your
physics lectures or chemistry lectures?
Like, yeah.
Everything is an oscillatory process.
That's what I learned in physics.
Uh
so, can can anyone give me specific
examples of like where these are used in
in science?
Where do you see these?
So, what sys- what physics systems or
chemistry systems can be described as
coupled oscillators?
Go on.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. So, one example might be
molecules, for example.
We can like a if you imagine like a CO2
molecule, we often we can describe that
as a coupled oscillator between
between
the the atoms.
There are there are other examples of
these couple of systems that we can
model with coupled oscillators. So,
yeah, see molecules are example of one.
Another are just
uh these uh suspension bridges, for
example, in engineering.
So, this is a really famous bridge that
uh
uh broke in half because they didn't
design the bridge well enough to deal
with the wind blowing over the over the
bridge and this caused the bridge to
oscillate really really strong
and eventually break.
Um we also see or we can you can also
think of neurons or neural activity as
coupled oscillators.
So, this is a this is a plot of uh of uh
of of the
uh dynamics of of neurons.
Uh
yeah, and you can think of these as
oscillatory processes that might have
some coupling between.
So, what we're going to do is uh
use this kind of PDE or
uh yeah, uh
actually some ODE to to to
design a neural network architecture to
help us solve this activity recognition
problem.
Uh so,
so, this is the 1D damped harmonic
oscillator. So, this is not coupled.
This is just a single oscillator and
this is the example that we already
talked about a lot when I introduced
physics-informed neural networks.
So, you guys should already know this
underlying second-order differential
equation. Uh
X here is the displacement of the
oscillator.
M is the mass of the oscillator. Mu is
the coefficient of friction. K is
uh the spring constant and F is some
external driving force that we can also
add to the oscillator.
So, force that we that we move the
oscillator by here, for example.
Um so, what determines the frequency of
of the oscillator? Anyone know?
Which which uh coefficients?
Yeah.
Yeah, primarily. I I think actually the
the coefficient of friction also turns
up uh as well when it's damped, but
yeah, primarily the spring constant and
the mass, yeah.
Uh and the the coefficient of friction
just tells us how quickly this this
oscillator just decays.
But you can imagine if we have some
driving force, then the energy might
increase. It might actually
get higher.
Okay, so,
this is the equivalent equation for the
for a coupled uh harmonic oscillator.
Uh
but there's quite a few changes. So, I'm
going to I'm going to tell you what
these changes are.
Uh so, the first change is now we're
modeling
not just the displacement of one
oscillator, but the oscillate the
displacement of n oscillators in
general.
So, now X here, instead of being a
scalar, is now going to be a vector.
So, what this becomes is instead of just
a single uh ordinary differential
equation, now this is a coupled set of
ordinary differential equations.
Um
and so,
what also happens is instead of these
mass and uh coefficient of friction and
spring constants as being scalar
quantities, in general, they can now
become uh matrices
which we times so, we write this write
this uh ODE system like this.
And the mass matrix is just going to be
diagonal matrix uh
which just pulls out the mass of each
oscillator.
But these W and V matrices here,
in general, if if if these oscillators
weren't uh coupled, if they were
completely independent, the W and V
matrices would also be diagonal.
But when we have some coupling, when we
have like springs connecting these
together, then these these uh these
matrices have
elements in their off-diagonal. So,
that's what introduces these kind of
coupling between these between these
variables.
Um the last thing that
we've assumed here is we've wrapped this
whole thing with a tanh.
So, what that is doing is is is
introducing a non-linearity into the
into the equation.
So, what physically do you think that
tanh does?
What is it saying?
Anyone know?
So, the left-hand side here is a is a
force term, right? It's the force it's
the acceleration mass times acceleration
is a force.
So, we're just saying the four the
maximum force in the oscillator is like
bounded. It can't go to infinity.
So, it's kind of a weird weird
approximation to make, but why we do
that and will will be obvious later.
Um
but yeah, we're just saying this is now
a non-linear version of the of the
oscillator.
So, can everyone see how we've kind of
generalized from a 1D oscillator to a
coupled system where we have these
matrices that tell us how they're
coupled
in general.
Again, I'm trying to explain this at the
highest level possible for you just to
get the idea but not to go into the
dynamics too much.
Okay, cool.
So,
uh we're just going to talk about
solving this and then next lecture I'll
talk about the actual way we use this to
solve that uh activity recognition task.
So, yeah, question to you, how how would
you solve this system of ODEs?
This is quite a hard question to ask,
but can anyone have like a general
starting point? How would you how would
you solve this?
And just assume that this mass this is
just one, so every every oscillator has
a mass of one.
Yeah? There are
numerical ODE solvers built for like
Yeah. oscillating systems. Yeah. Which
probably good for this. Sure, yeah.
Yeah, I guess I How would
what underlying algorithm would they use
then?
Uh
I mean, it's still you know,
often the system will be from
Yeah. from something.
Sure, yeah.
Yeah.
Anyone think about the simplest possible
approach?
Okay, yeah, it's it's hard. So, this is
how you would how you would do it uh
or one way you would do it, the simplest
way maybe,
um is you would introduce a velocity
variable, so you just, you know, this is
the velocity of the oscillators.
And plug that into this uh underlying
ODE.
Uh and then you end up with a
first-order ODE just in terms of the
velocity of the oscillator.
Um and and the the X value as well, and
then you can just uh discretize this
this differential
uh this dV by dT, so the acceleration,
numerically, and then that just ends up
with two two expressions for for X uh by
discretizing this,
uh and for V by discretizing this.
So, again, this is the simplest possible
approach. It may not be a good approach
if you want a very accurate Yeah, rapid
shaking his head, I know it.
I'm aware of of of that, so. But just
for the purpose of
of this NDE example, uh this is uh
this is how we might do it.
Actually, this is an interesting
question, like um like on like
seriously, uh
when you're solving neural differential
equations, should you really care about
the solution being accurate, like the
solver giving you an accurate solution?
Uh especially when you're training them
to do the these like um machine learning
tasks, like what we actually care about
at the end of the day is that the that
the NDE learns the inputs and outputs of
the task rather than maybe solving the
underlying PDE. But I think it That's a
kind of controversial topic. You You
kind of have to think about what what
your end goal is, but yeah.
Okay, so
yeah, we discretize in time we do this.
let me draw this out as a as a graph
again.
Um
and
uh
again, this is just the graph is just
showing given the kind of initial
location initial position and the
initial velocity or the velocity at time
t, the position at time t.
Uh this is the graph that computes the
the displacement at time t plus one and
the velocity at time t plus one.
And
uh it does a bunch of
really complicated operations, passes X
through this tanH function,
does a bunch of weights times by the the
the the V values,
adds it together, does some other stuff,
and and it also takes in the the force,
the external force that we're applying
to the system as an an an additional
input to the
to this cell.
So, now that
I hope I hopefully you're starting to
realize that drawing out these
time-stepping algorithms as graphs is
very useful. It helps us interpret them.
So, so what does this look like to you
now?
If you think back to that um RNN that I
just talked about,
can anyone draw like any analogies to an
RNN in this case?
So, if you just forget about all the
operations in here,
and you just draw this you just have a
box here, a black box that takes in some
uh state here,
takes in another input and then produces
an update of the state.
Isn't that just what I described an RNN
as?
Doesn't an RNN take like a a hidden
state here,
take in some input and then update the
hidden state?
Some people are nodding their heads.
So, hopefully I can convince you that
we can actually just think of this this
thing as an
a recurrent neural network.
It's taking a hidden state, it's it
takes an input to update the hidden
state, and then produces an output uh
output hidden state.
So, instead of this being like a fully
connected network like we would use in
an RNN or maybe a CNN uh
cell or an LSTM cell or a GRU cell,
what we've defined here is like a a
custom physics cell inside of our RNN.
So,
we can use exactly if if we're going to
still think about this human activity
recognition task,
we can just swap out whatever we had in
here before in our RNN with this custom
physics cell.
And and the question is that we then ask
is, okay, so what what are we actually
going to learn?
What are the what is the learnable
components of this RNN of this RNN cell?
And uh
one option is to learn these weight
uh weight and W and V matrices here,
which we then just reinterpret as the
weights of the weights of the RNN cell.
And now it makes kind of more sense why
I put that tanH into the PDE. It's just
it gives it like a non-linear
non-linearity or like an activation
function of this uh
of this hidden state computation.
Who follows me?
Or who's confused?
Any questions?
So, we're taking it a We're taking We're
doing the same thing. We're We're
defining a
uh a differential equation,
we're discretizing the differential
equation,
and interpreting interpreting that as a
as a neural network.
And in this case, we can interpret this
as like a an RNN.
Where these W and V matrices, which if
you go back to the underlying
differential
underlying differential equation,
the W and V matrices here are are the uh
the damping coefficients in this and the
spring constants of the different
oscillators.
So, we're going to learn them. We're
going to say we don't understand what
these what the spring constant is and
what the damping coefficient is,
but given examples of the of the outputs
of the system, can we try and learn
those underlying coefficients?
That's what we're doing.
Um
So, I think I'll stop there and we'll
talk about the performance of this next
next lecture. So,
yeah, thanks thanks for coming. See you
see you on Friday.
So, yeah, we train it just like we would
train a a standard RNN, same training
data. Training data All the data you
need is just examples of these
accelerometer uh time series and and the
class uh of whatever the person was
doing at that point in time.
Uh so, typically uh to create a single
class prediction, you'll just take like
a a single window of time time values,
maybe 10 seconds or something.
And uh
what this paper did, this is uh a paper
from our our lab at ETH, um
so who who who proposed this kind of
architecture, this discretization of
these coupled oscillators and and the
interpretation of that as an RNN.
And they uh
yeah, they compared this uh co-RNN, so
it's called a coupled oscillatory RNN, a
co-RNN,
compared this architecture to many other
kind of state-of-the-art uh
recurrent neural networks and like LSTMs
and GRUs and other more uh
advanced variants of those.
And at least for this uh task of human
activity recognition, they performed
very very well, very competitive with
these other other methods.
So, what kind of was really interesting
for me when I was reading this paper was
yeah, this
for me, it's intuitive that such a model
with like oscillatory dynamics would
perform well when the data is
oscillatory. But actually, these models,
these coupled oscillatory RNNs, also
work well for other tasks where it
doesn't seem oscillatory.
So, this is the kind of accuracy on
IMDb.
Anyone heard of this data set?
This is a uh movie data set, and I think
it's uh to do with sentiment on the
movies or or something like this. So, it
doesn't I don't think that's what I
mean, maybe it is, but uh it's really
interesting that these models perform
well on on that data as well.
Yeah. So, this model, this co-RNN, is a
simple one, just the Euler
Yes, uh
they proposed a few different
discretizations. They have an implicit
version as well.
Um
and I'm not sure exactly which one they
which one they chose, but yeah.
Um
and
so, this is really highlighting the
point that even though we're using a PDE
to define a network architecture, we're
kind of moving away from
the fundamental system that it's uh
uh used to model and just using it for
some other other machine learning task.
It's kind of interesting.
Yeah. Was the accuracy measured
according to the data you have, or was
it measured to the actual observation
of the body experience.
Uh so I think it's all real data.
I think they just did a a lab experiment
of people walking and labeling.
Um and I think it's just test what it is
test test accuracy. So it's not an about
distribution test.
Okay, so you can imagine you could come
up with your own PDE. It doesn't have to
be a coupled oscillator. It could be
like a non-linear pendulum or a
reaction-diffusion equation. You can
just take your pick and discretize it
and train it as a new model and and it's
kind of interesting to interpret.
So that they did a
uh One other thing which is very
interesting is you can plot. So remember
the hidden state of this RNN
uh of this coupled oscillatory RNN
is is exactly just telling you how these
oscillators uh their displacement
evolves over time.
Cuz that's that's the hidden state,
right? It's telling you the displacement
and velocity of those oscillators.
So you can actually just plot the hidden
state as it as a function of uh
time. Basically, you know, the hidden
state
the hidden state at each time step here.
And what you see is yeah, the it looks
very much like a coupled oscillator. It
oscillates. The hidden state is evolving
with lots of oscillations that are all
coupled together.
So that's really cool. It gives us kind
of a way to interpret how the hidden
state is like evolving.
Um what's even more interesting is and
in the paper they show this and you can
see see it the paper for the proof.
Um if you just think about these coupled
oscillators as they're moving around, if
I don't have any force put into the
system, then the system just obeys
conservation of energy, right? There's
no energy no energy put into the system.
It just keeps keeps if there's no
dampening that it just keeps the same.
And so what that does is just
places a bound on the maximum amplitude
of a single oscillator. Like it can't go
above a certain amplitude.
Uh and so that's really nice because
that actually leads to the result that
inside the hidden state these these
co-RNNs won't explode. Like the value's
not it's not going to explode and that
means that the if you think about back
propagating through it that you're not
going to have a problem of exploding
gradients in these in these models.
So they show this more mathematically,
but this is a really desirable property
of RNNs. This is one of the limitations
of standard RNNs is this so-called like
vanishing gradient or exploding gradient
issue.
So a really nice kind of
uh
interpretation of of of this type of
model.
And again, this is because we've used a
PDE which we know a lot about to kind of
build this model instead of just kind of
guessing what the model structure should
be.
Okay.
Any questions on this? Otherwise, I'm
going to move on to something different.
Okay.